Eddie is in Florida hi Eddie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
Merry Christmas
merry Christmas to you what's up I'm on
baby steps
the end of baby step two I got nothing
left but my wife's camera hi Oh 12 grand
on it and my house 124 and I got 48 in
cash twelve and gold coins and that's it
I think you misunderstood what baby step
two is baby step two is you've sold
everything except for retirement funds
to be out of debt so you would write a
check today and be debt-free except your
house and pay off the car yes sir
like like 18 weeks ago yeah but yeah
we're two months pregnant with our
second child okay but you have 40,000
how much do you say you had the savings
48 48 you know twelve on the car yeah
yeah so you have 36 thousand bucks left
in the account and a baby on the way
he'll be okay and I got the 401k I can
do the match but here's my question this
doesn't fit in the plan and it's
something I wanted to do for a long time
I've been with my wife 12 years she lost
both her parents her brother is on
disability and he's in a bad
neighborhood in a bad apartment and I
have an opportunity to put 20% down on a
small house around the corner from us
take out a second mortgage and he can
his check will cover the mortgage
we move them closer to us but I'll have
two mortgages I'll have one on my house
and one on his house
and but he'll be able to pay for it I'm
handy I put a roof on our own house I
just didn't know if this would end up
sinking our ship or if I should just
stick to the plan and do this ten years
from now or I don't know because none of
the other babies on the way and that's
kind of my main focus yeah it should be
yeah you need to have an emergency fund
set aside out of your debt free and out
of your cell your coins and
your emergency fund of three to six
months set aside out of that and then
you start baby steps four five and six
which is 15 percent of your income going
into retirement start talking about a
kid's college fund when baby comes and
then we start talking about paying off
your homework as quick as you can
what is your household income fifty
three six three or five three five three
and our total monthly expenses are
twenty seven hundred and that includes
food and utilities and everything okay
so let's set ten thousand of the 36
aside that's remaining after the Camry
as your emergency fund that leaves us
twenty six and you said twelve and gold
coins right yeah which puts us back to
48 or thirty-eight I'm sorry
thirty-eight that we put towards the
hundred and twenty-four on the house
and now the houses now this is all after
mama comes home with four with the baby
but now you only owe like eighty
thousand dollars on your house you make
fifty thousand it's not ten years it's
about three years four years you're
going to be have your house paid off
yeah so fine that's mortgage in a second
how no hundred twenty thousand dollar
house to put my brother-in-law and you
if you need to help him help him a
little bit with cash flow renting
something better than where he is until
you can get your house paid off and you
can save up and pay cash for the house
you move him into we quit borrowing
money that's how we get out of debt okay
and that so that's what I would do I
love that you want to help him and I
love that you've got this angst pulling
in your brain between taking care of
your child and helping your
brother-in-law
you're just a giving guy you're a guy
that wants to help everybody and that's
a good thing what you have to do most on
you're probably a spender - I'm a
spender and most of us that are spenders
are givers and so what I figured out a
few years ago was the if I'll manage the
spending and keep things prioritized it
enables me to become wealthy
so that I can give more and it changes
my giving so that's what I want you to
do
and don't let your giving keep your
wealthy your wealth from building which
will keep you from giving so that that's
you've just got to keep the stuff
prioritized so I don't mind you helping
him I would not buy him a house until
you can pay cash for it after your home
is paid off but I don't think that's but
about three years from now that the
house is paid off and then shortly after
that with no house payment or payments
of any kind I mean you could work an
extra job and save up money to buy a
little house pretty quick to put him in
and then he can pay you rent equal to
his income or whatever if you wanted to
do that which would be pure cash flow or
you could just lame live there if you
wanted to is it active as a ministry or
you know just act of taking care of him
or something it wouldn't kill you
because it's paid for it changes the
game when it's paid for or if something
happened and he just took off and
they're your health left holding that
house and you got a payment he's not
paying the payment anymore
you know you're stuck now you got a
relationship with your brother-in-law
the strained and we just don't want
being all of that so take get your house
paid off and then save up and pay cash
no I would not buy a rental right now
and those are the reasons behind it so
that you can be in a position to do more
even even more later